all right so it's official Superman has
been cast for the new Superman movie and
it's this henry cavill guy and people
have asked me what i think about it and
my thoughts on it hurt i have no idea i
don't know who he is like who is that
guy what's he been in and yeah you just
found out that i don't watch the tutors
god bless IMDB but I did find out that
he's Albert Mondego from Count of Monte
Cristo the son so I thought that was
interesting I mean you know that's cool
and he looks the part you know he's got
the chiseled jaw the starlets do not
hurt the people I shall stuff you
villain see I'll probably work out but
we'll see other bit of news in the not
official rumor news is that there might
be another villain in The Dark Knight
Rises and it might be Hugo Strange
played by Robin Williams might be
might not be because
Robin Williams did work with Christopher
Nolan on insomnia and for those of you
who saw one hour photo you know
firsthand that Robin Williams could play
a really obsessed and deranged human
being but also you don't want to clutter
your movie up with a bunch of villains
you start going the Schumacher route at
that point not a good thing that's
called the death of a franchise again so
if Robin Williams were to play dr. Hugo
Strange I think he could do it really
well I'm just not sure I want to see
three villains in the Dark Knight Rises
or two villains one kind of antihero of
love interest still might be a bit much
might feel a little too cluttered so
Henry Cavill officially cast as Superman
and Robin Williams possibly playing dr.
Hugo Strange what do you think about
these tidbits of information comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]